on this episode we talk about pets
cutting through the noise and
vaynermedia's social accounts
[Music]
[Music]
ask Gary B
[Music]
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 171 of the ask gary
vee show late in the year india the Jets
have won three straight games so I'm in
a good mood today I apologize everybody
who you know big ups to the vaynernation
that's been following my new website
Stefan get that you know actually take
overlook holes actually people my face
small in the corner and have the whole
website here it's a little more editing
but I'll take it
Big Ups everybody who's checked out the
new website I appreciate it and for a
lot of you calling me out because the
new calendar app which I know we also
have to throw a right hook for so let's
get that up calendar app please download
and check that out something really cool
if you don't want to miss any more of my
public streamings or my free of public
events or my keynotes we were looking at
a lot of the feedback that I've been
getting in the last year and when we
updated the site the biggest thing was
people wanting to know when I was in
town and things were available so we
created this app it's really cool but
surely downloaded syncs with your
calendar but we put there be an
askgaryvee show yesterday cuz they were
supposed to be what do you think there
was only probably four or five times in
the entire year that we were planning on
doing the show we had to cancel because
I just couldn't get it in right because
November in December yeah anyway so
interesting that like of course now we
have the app we make the promise and we
did do the show yes sir so we're back in
the saddle for everybody who's been
giving me huge love for the dailyvees
thank you so much we've done 2d rock is
mi a to the beginning of the year so
there'll be no more dailyvees until
January but then we're going to come
hard two to three a week we're looking
to do I'm excited about that huge
feedback on that bread I don't know if
you notice that and so I'm so funny you
should at least yeah got it and so uh
and so that's good and that's it you
know going to Dallas I've now made the
commitment to go to every Jets game this
year
so with that India let's get into the
show
my pad yeah that was that was kind of
nostalgic I missed the show I've been on
in that little mi a so busy end of the
year
hope you're hustling as well let's do it
Matt how would you market a pet toy a
wholesale brand now looking to build a
direct-to-consumer presence Matt first
and foremost I'm saddened by your
concern because you literally are
playing in one of the three or four best
genres like you're selling to pet
enthusiasts have you looked at the
psychology and emotion of people that
love their pets there are people that
really really look there are enormous
amounts of human beings in the world
that love their pets more than their
family I mean so you're talking about a
high emotion category Instagram is
littered literally littered go to the
hat I mean stuff outlets let's go
functionality here it's not super
complicated there's something called
Instagram yeah open it up
you literally hit the search button you
go to search yeah literally put dogs
dogs stick with me here
this is massively complicated slow
internet dogs tags sticking with me here
I don't know how you're zooming in
Stefan I'm sorry for the slow internet
should be on the Wi-Fi all right dogs of
Instagram oh I don't know 34 million
hashtags dogs 22 million hashtags dogs
to ram 13 million dogs sitting two
million these this is are you nuts like
start putting out content on Instagram
start tagging your stuff with these tags
that everybody uses and use hashtag
riding to build awareness and it doesn't
cost you anything except for the
production of the content which on a
scrappy business level should be free
because it's your time time is valuable
but it should be free and so Instagram
for sure because the attention graph is
there you can buy Facebook ads against
dog lovers or fans of dogs all day long
we had the benefit of working with a dog
brand company our conversion rates and
engagement we're at the highest of
anything we played with you know
obviously we're watching the show and
maybe you just want to get your question
on but this is very basic Facebook Ads
Instagram creative with using the
hashtags there go search I would run ads
I made an investment in a company called
barkbox they have a Content play their
ads on that site from what I hear
burning extremely well frontier
advertising not because it's investment
uh maybe because I want to be
historically right
I don't nothing of it it's like it's
it's just a place that a lot of dog
people are spending a lot of tension
there's so many place I mean this kind
of pissed me off India this is not the
right I don't know if you asked me this
question on purpose to get me going you
did got it okay so you tried to razz him
were you razzing him a little bit for
his persistence what's his name Matt
first of all I love the persistence razz
in the I like it second it's dogs and
cats and parents and people love this
crap I mean are you nuts
easy easy just uh I'm almost wondering
if you're just crippled by how much you
can do verses by being curious of what
you should do yeah I'm pumped we've got
it we've got a new wish make that a
medium article or the new Gavin a
terrific stuff on mobile is fire Zach
killed it alright John asks I know
you're the brand but wire vaynermedia's
social accounts so whatever
why are those outlets afterthoughts
that's a really good point we we decided
to take on this question it's not a fun
question we are we are not doing a good
enough job on the vaynermedia account
it's a 100% my fault we've had people in
the past and a good rotation we were
when we were two or three hundred people
I think in 2016 it became a secondary
priority as some of those people
graduated to more senior jobs or more
responsibilities or or something was
lost in translation you know we're the
real answer there's two very interesting
answers so the answer the first answer
is it wasn't a priority it stems from
the top it lost its momentum and I
didn't create infrastructure to fix it
the second part is probably more
interesting which is our funnel of
applicants and high quality employees
and new business is so high that we're
taking it's the same reason I don't
think Apple is a good advertiser when
you have the best product a bird in the
same way I always say the greatest
advertising in the world doesn't fix
your [ __ ] product when you have the best
product the worst advertising doesn't
hurt you as much either could hurt you
but I'd be I wouldn't be naive to think
that we maybe missed out on some clients
because well they're not doing their own
social as well as they used to or could
be because we used to be best in class
and to you know some applicants were
like well they don't think that serious
so yes I think we'd probably run on the
fact that I'm just so strong and good at
it and there is that proxy the way you
ask the question but it is I probably
was willing to answer this question to
shame myself into fixing that in 2016 as
my tracking the I'm putting you in
charge of shaming me you know not in
charge of the Boehner accounts but in
charge of me putting together the team
in January that will start executing in
February or the system because I do have
this idea of since we have so many
employees creating a calendar where one
employee takes over the account every
day for the entire year
you like that that's a clever little
idea also let them do whatever no I'm
not you know you know I love to run it
capitalists they come not scared of
anybody doing inappropriate things
they'll just get fired and well I own up
to it it's not super complicated I hate
my company this is a good way to answer
something else like what are we gonna
like check the content and like give
them a bunch of hand the handbooks and
rules know if you know if Marv like
sucks at it and like puts up
inappropriate pictures of himself like
you'll get fired yeah we're gonna go
hard on that cool next one Josiah Josiah
asks would you recommend a white legal
video player or YouTube for media
companies looking to monetize video
content both if you have an advertising
department that can get your own sales
team to sell pre-roll or integration
within your own video player that gives
you more flexibility than what YouTube
could based on what your advertisers or
partners would want from the player and
that you could justify building a player
for a couple hundred thousand dollars
because you have a million dollar
sponsorship but this sponsorship wanted
these unique things that YouTube didn't
have you do that if you're like 99% of
the rest of the world use YouTube it was
tight
pat flynn big time guy a lot of people
watching the show listen there's podcast
first of all Pat you took forever to
[ __ ] so nice to me hey what's up Pat
from smart passive income quick question
when you get a new idea when a new idea
pops into your head how do you do you
have a validation process before
actually taking action on that idea to
make sure it's worth it or not do you
have a vetting process does your team
help you I'm curious because you know a
lot of us entrepreneurs we had a ton of
ideas how do you know which ones are
gonna work or not
and to follow it up do you have an
example that's a great great great great
great great great question I have two
processes one is completely emotional
the other one is completely rational
there have been ideas allah the
askgaryvee show where literally in one
shot though it's percolated a little bit
in one moment i go i execute against the
idea and i let the results speak for
themselves and i could stop it you know
for every time I look like a hero where
I make the first episode of Wine Library
TV or askgaryvee and I say we're gonna
look back at this and this was right
there are seven other things I've done
like that which are floating in the
internets and we're gonna look back at
this and be like yeah my first picture
from Flickr my first picture for Flickr
do you have it somewhere my first
picture from Flickr I drew out gourmet
library calm drew it and I said one day
this will be one of the most iconic
pictures in my life or something like
that and it was because at that time I
thought I was gonna launch gourmet
library calm and I knew that I was gonna
build a hundred million dollar gourmet
business what happened was I started
wine leveraged feed two months later as
well and that became the thing and I
never got around to really doing gourmet
library so I think that I've got that
intuitive part the other part is like
Wine Library TV since February since
really like March or April of 2005 I
knew that I wanted to do a YouTube show
that it was gonna be big that YouTube is
gonna be big but it took me until
February 6 to start Wine Library TV I
knew that I wanted to do an e-commerce
site in 94 but I really didn't launch it
until 96 but really run it until 9:00
viii I I know that I'm going to buy a
brand one day Puma
Snickers you know paps B ribbon but I'm
percolating and learning for ten years
before that moment so I have both but uh
Pat really the answer is it's very
internal I don't go to my dad or to
Britney be like hey Bret what do you
think like I don't give a [ __ ] what
Brittany thinks it's now that is either
a strength or a weakness sorry Brit I
don't that's either a strength or a
weakness but I want to give you the
truth which is I go very internal I feel
it with myself I care you know what's
funny it's not okay I don't care what
Brittany says as my consultant or
teammate I can't what Brittany does as a
consumer I respect the market over my
friends my family my the people I
respect and even myself and so I think
the way to find out what the markets
gonna feel and do is by giving them a
chance to react to it
so I let the things that I feel the most
bubble up and then I execute against
those things and I let the chips fall
where they may
you found the picture see this is so
cool because look this I mean I'm sorry
gonna put this up some on the so is very
similar to show that's unbelievable
one day December 30th 2005 oh my god
this is literally what's tonight
this is literally literally a decade ago
like two weeks short of a decade ago
there's a picture of the pasta I ate
while I drew out gourmet library calm
and one day everyone will know why this
pic is so amazing and I'm gonna tell you
why this pic is so amazing though I
didn't execute on gourmet library ten
years ago and big shout out to Eric
Kastner and John Kay who were there with
me that day even though I didn't this
date was the two-week period this was
the height of the holidays this date
represents the day that I knew that I
wasn't going to be in the wine business
the rest of my life this picture really
represent
it's the transformation into what all of
you have known me to become over the
last 10 years I told you one day
everybody would understand why this
pictus uh cuz it's so amazing that's
cool a little bit emotional about that
yes Tellez asks how do I cut through the
[ __ ] and engage to become the number one
knowledge leader ah t-this is such a
good question that great new you're just
getting very strategic about your book
ending of questions I'm very proud of
you actually say you've really grown and
you're in your deejaying of question
skills great year for you the reason I
said that is India knows that I'm gonna
go off on this one mainly because it's
such a simple answer T yes there's so
much noise and there's so much bad crap
and the way to break through this is
crazy now stick with me is to actually
be the best and actually have the skills
that allow you to break through being a
thought leader is no different than
being the best football player in
America how does one become with all the
people that want to be a professional
football player you know 80 percent of
dudes that are 15 60 whatever I don't
know right of all those people how do
you become Aaron Rodgers crazy thing ya
have to have the natural ability and
then you have to put so much work into
that ability that you rise above all the
other people that equally had or around
the same level of that ability how do
you become the thought leader or the one
in your space you need to be the best
the reason I was the one in the white
faces for 15 years since I was 15 before
I started Wine Library TV I had learned
an insane amount about wine I had
executed for eight years running the
fastest growing and then ultimately one
of the biggest wine businesses in
America I amassed my knowledge I went
all-in I worked 15 hours a day and then
I started content on what would then
become one of the most important
communication tools of our time called
YouTube on top of the Internet and then
after I showed everybody the way every
other wine personality decided to get a
camera like this and do it - that's what
mm
679 was in wine world they're like we if
that idiot can do it I can do it and
then I had to be the best and that's
what this business shows about there's a
lot of other business shows either I'm
gonna be the most valuable for you or
the second most valuable or the third
most valuable or you're not gonna watch
me it's the quality you break through
not by your tactics you break through by
your ability and your skills it's the
truth
that's what's so great about a market
the customer gets to decide not you not
me not you and so you go out there and
you execute and then you let the chips
fall do you know how many people are
running around on YouTube and Instagram
and Twitter right now trying to do my
tactics a lot see it every day do they
have the same business acumen do they
have the same business skills do they
have the same 20 years of experience of
running businesses do they have the same
history of being right where the
consumer behavior is going in the
country not as much and there are others
that are and there's plenty of you
watching right now there's a 16 year old
watching this right now who's got more
chops than me who's gonna put in just
this work as me and he's gonna go out
and win there's a girl right now in
Alabama who has more natural DNA to
understand what the consumers are gonna
do in 2020 and 2030 and if she puts in
the work because she's gonna she's gonna
go and she's gonna be bigger and more
successful and more dominant than me
that's what's awesome about the game
that's how you break through the clutter
you break through all that crap that you
decided is crap by being better than
that crap now let's just see if you're
not that crap too question of the day
how many more of these do we have before
I go away - we're gonna do one tomorrow
in front no tomorrow I'm in Chattanooga
and Charlotte so one more Friday and
that's it so second last episode of the
year there's a lot of family time unless
I might ask you to meet me at the Jets
game cuz I'm flying back from Jets
Patriots but let's assume this is we got
two more so what I want to know let's go
go go New Year's resolution okay
something to go with question of the day
because I'm glad it's back I missed it
question of the day what are you doing
for the holidays I'm in a surprise and
delight kind of mood so let's see how
detail people get on them on the
Instagram on the Facebook on the Twitter
a lot of people say that I'm the Twitter
and let me know on twitter facebook
instagram and we're out of youtube and
that's it oh yes we are doing a
exclusive podcast question but for
everybody who's watching on those
channels you're out I feel like I'm on
these radios when you've got a local and
a national broadcast everybody's
listening on the podcast I'll be with
you in a second for the rest of you you
keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]